American women you are not oppressed
I know everybody is telling you you are
but the truth is if you are a woman living in the United States in the year 2024
you have more luxuries and more freedoms
than 99% of human beings who have ever walked this earth
if you wanna run for public office
you can run for public office
if you wanna own land or a business or a home
you can do that
if you wanna go to school and become a doctor or a lawyer or anything else
you can if you wanna have children
you can have children if you get pregnant and want an abortion
you can have one if you wanna get pregnant
and then decide in the third trimester that you actually don't wanna be a mom
then you can just hop on over to one of the six or seven blue states
that will allow you to do that
and you can do it no questions asked
how about it you wanna get married
you can get married if you wanna get divorced
you can get divorced and legally
you will probably have the upper hand in that
to be honest
the most outspoken people who claim to be victims and all of this are
well to do white women that's who I'm seeing
and the be Frank
all of the drama and the theatrics around this
are why a lot of people don't take women seriously
you can't look around at this country and all the freedoms that we have
and all of the luxury that we have
and claim to be oppressed
you just can't I get it
it sucks when your candidate doesn't win an election
especially if you've been invested in it
especially if you feel very passionate about them
but let's be honest with ourselves
we are privileged beyond belief
and if you look at history
and you look at your ancestors
and you look at the women and the people who came before you
you will very quickly realize just how privileged you are
victimhood is real and oppression is real
countries that victimize women exist
but ours is not we are not victims
and that is a wonderful thing